Using our regression
models, we would
like to predict before
the season starts
how many games the 2002
Oakland A's will win.
To do this, we first
have to predict
how many runs the
team will score
and how many runs
they will allow.
These models use
team statistics.
However, when we are
predicting for the 2002 Oakland
A's before the
season has occurred,
the team is probably different
than it was the year before.
So we don't know
the team statistics.
But we can estimate these
statistics using past player
performance.
This approach assumes that
past performance correlates
with future performance
and that there
will be few injuries
during the season.
Using this approach, we can
estimate the team statistics
for 2002 by using the
2001 player statistics.
Let's start by making a
prediction for runs scored.
At the beginning
of the 2002 season,
the Oakland A's had 24
batters on their roster.
Using the 2001 regular season
statistics for these players,
we can estimate that team
on-base percentage will be
about 0.339 and team slugging
percentage will be about 0.430.
We built the following linear
regression equation in R
to predict runs scored.
If we plug in 0.339 for
on-base percentage and 0.430
for slugging percentage, we
predict that the 2002 Oakland
A's will score about 805 runs.
Similarly, we can make a
prediction for runs allowed.
At the beginning
of the 2002 season,
the Oakland A's had 17
pitchers on their roster.
Using the 2001 regular season
statistics for these players,
we can estimate that team
opponent on-base percentage
will be about 0.307 and team
opponent slugging percentage
will be about 0.373.
Our regression equation
to predict runs allowed
was as follows.
By plugging in
0.307 for opponents
on-base percentage and 0.373 for
opponents slugging percentage,
we predict that the 2002
Oakland A's will allow 622 runs.
We can now make a prediction for
how many games they will win.
Our regression equation to
predict wins is as follows.
We predicted 805 runs
scored and 622 runs allowed.
We can plug in the difference
between runs scored
and runs allowed to
predict that the A's
will win 100 games in 2002.
Paul DePodesta used a similar
approach to make predictions.
It turns out that our
predictions and Paul's
predictions closely
match actual performance.
Our prediction for runs
scored was 805 runs.
Paul predicted between
800 and 820 runs.
And it turns out that the
2002 Oakland A's actually
scored 800 runs.
For runs allowed,
we predicted 622.
Paul DePodesta predicted
between 650 and 670.
It turns out that the Oakland
A's actually allowed 653 runs.
For wins, we predicted that
they would win 100 games.
Paul predicted that they would
win between 93 and 97 games.
And they actually 103 games.
These predictions
show us that by using
publicly available data
and simple analytics,
we can predict very close
to what actually happened
before the season even started.
It turns out that the A's
won a league record in 2002
by winning 20 games in a row.
And they won 1 more game
than the previous year
and made it to the
playoffs once again.